[Music]
after six months
i couldn't see the value in it i had no
idea what i wanted to do with my life
and no idea how college was going to
help me figure it out
so i decided to drop out and trust that
it would all work out okay
it was pretty scary at the time but
looking back it was one of the best
decisions i ever made
the minute i dropped out i could stop
taking the required classes that didn't
interest me
and begin dropping in on the ones that
looked far more interesting
it wasn't all romantic i didn't have a
dorm room so i slept on the floor in
friends rooms
i returned coke bottles for the five
cent deposits to buy food with
and i would walk the seven miles across
town every sunday night
to get one good meal a week at the hari
krishna temple and much of what i
stumbled into
by following my curiosity and intuition
turned out to be priceless later on
you can't connect the dots looking
forward you can only connect them
looking backwards so you have to trust
that the dots will somehow connect in
your future
you have to trust in something your gut
destiny
life karma whatever because believing
that the dots will connect down the road
will give you the confidence to follow
your heart even when it leads you off
the well-worn path
and that will make all the difference
i was lucky i found what i loved to do
early in life waz and i started apple in
my parents
garage when i was 20. we worked hard and
in 10 years
apple had grown from just the two of us
in a garage into a two billion dollar
company with over 4 000 employees
we just released our finest creation the
macintosh a year earlier and i just
turned 30.
so at 30 i was out and very publicly out
what had been the focus of my entire
adult life was gone
and it was devastating i really didn't
know what to do for a few months
i was a very public failure and i even
thought about running away from the
valley
but something slowly began to dawn on me
i still loved what i did the turn of
events at apple had not
changed that one bit i'd been rejected
but i was still in love and so i decided
to start over
i didn't see it then but it turned out
that getting fired from apple was the
best thing that could have ever happened
to me
the heaviness of being successful was
replaced by the lightness
of being a beginner again less sure
about everything
it freed me to enter one of the most
creative periods of my life
during the next five years i started a
company named next
another company named pixar and fell in
love with an amazing woman who would
become my wife
pixar went on to create the world's
first computer animated feature film
toy story and is now the most successful
animation studio
in the world in a remarkable turn of
events
apple bought next and i returned to
apple
i'm pretty sure none of this would have
happened if i hadn't been fired from
apple
it was awful tasting medicine but i
guess the patient needed it
sometimes people come to me and say i
want to start a company and i say why
he said oh i want to make lots of money
i said forget it that's not
a good enough reason you will not most
likely you will not succeed most people
that have started companies
because they want to make lots of money
i haven't seen very many of those
succeed
the ones that succeed are people that
come sometimes they don't even want to
start a company they just have an idea
that they want to get out
expressed out into the world and
oftentimes they have to start a company
because nobody else will listen to them
my entire life's been spent only in one
industry which is this one
and but i've been in it now for about 15
years and i've seen a lot of people make
a lot of things i've seen a lot of
people fail a lot of things and my
my point of view on this or my
observation is
that the doers are the major thinkers
uh the people that really create the
things that change this industry
are both the thinker doer in one person
and if we really go back and we examine
uh you know did leonardo have a guy
off to the side that was thinking five
years out in the future what he would
paint or
the technology he would use to paint it
of course not
leonardo was the artist but he also
mixed all his own paints he also
was a fairly good chemist knew about
pigments
knew about human anatomy and combining
all of those skills together
the art and the science the thinking and
the doing
was what resulted in the exceptional
result
and there is no difference in our
industry the people that have really
made the contributions have been the
thinkers and the doers
when you uh a lot of people of course
it's it's very easy to take credit for
the thinking
the doing is more concrete but somebody
it's very easy for somebody to say oh i
thought of this three years ago
but usually when you dig a little deeper
you find that the people that really
did it were also the people that really
worked through the hard intellectual
problems as well
[Music]
sometimes life's going to hit you in the
head with a brick don't lose faith
i'm convinced that the only thing that
kept me going was that i loved what i
did
you've got to find what you love and
that is as true for work
as it is for your lovers your work is
going to fill a large part of your life
and the only way to be truly satisfied
is to do what you believe is great work
and the only way to do great work is to
love what you do
if you haven't found it yet keep looking
and don't
settle as with all matters of the heart
you'll know when you find it
and like any great relationship it just
gets better and better
as the years roll on so keep looking
don't settle
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here